>> Thank you, reverend parker.
And thank all of you for being
here.
I want to thank Kamala for her
not only her capacity to do what
he she does, but the fire with
which she brings.
To all the members of congress,
including representative
Thompson, representative Davis
and senator dick Durbin, who we
wish a speedy recovery from
covid.
And who have long fought to
honor the till family.
It's not new to any of them.
To the till family, it's an
honor to be with you again.
I quite frankly found myself
trying to temper my anger as I
was writing it.
I'm not joking.
I can't a fathom what it must
have been like.
It's hard to believe I was 12
years old.
And I know no matter how much
time has passed, how many
birthdays, how many
anniversaries, it's hard to
relive this.
It brings it all back as if it
happened yesterday.
The images in your head, things
you remember.
But it's inspiring to see how
many of your family have
continued as mothers courage to
find faith in pain.
Insisting on an open casket for
her murdered, and might aim,
maimed and mutilated son.
14 years old.
She said, let the people see
what I have seen.
Let the people see what I have
seen.
My god.
All of us who have lost children
in other ways, how hard it is to
close the casket or keep it open
or what a debate it is.
To see the child that had been
maimed.
In a country that the world saw
and his mother as a story of a
family's promise and loss in the
nation's reckoning with hate.
Overwhelming abuse of power,
brutality.
It's hard to fathom.
It's hard to fathom for me.
Today on what we have been his
82nd birthday, we add another
chapter to the story of healing.
Just as we join together when I
signed the law in his name to
make lynching a federal crime,
and think how long that took to
happen, we screened the movie
"Till" at the white house.
Today we join together as a sign
a proclamation designating
Emmett till national monument in
both Illinois and in
Mississippi.
[ Applause ]
>> We talked about wanting to do
this, but to support from the
community has been overwhelming.
I thank them for their
leadership.
In a time when there are those
who seek to ban books, bury
history, we're making it clear,
crystal clear.
While darkness and denialism can
hide much, they erase nothing.
We can't just choose to learn
what we want to know.
We have to learn what we should
know.
We should know about our
country.
We should know everything.
The good, the bad, the truth.
That's what great nations do,
and we are a great nation.
That's what they do.
Is only with truth comes healing
and another step forward towards
forming a more perfect union.
We have a hell of a long way to
go.
That's what's happening.
S that's what's going to happen.
To learn the history of Emmett
till, through our national
monument.
Telling the truth in the full
history of our nation is
important.
It's important to our children,
our grandchildren, our great
grandchildren, to our nation as
a whole.
You have said it before.
It's a lesson I learned.
I came out of the civil rights
movement as a kid, I used to say
to pass something that's good,
you make hate go away.
Hate never goes away.
It just hides.
It hides under the rocks.
Given a little bit of oxygen,
like bad people, it comes
roaring out again.
It's up to all of us to deal
with that.
It's up to all of us to stop it.
The best way to do that is with
the truth.
I think it applies here.
Silence is complicity.
I will not be silent, nor will
you be silent.
We have really critical work
ahead.
And my administration is
committed to leading the path
forward.
I know the members of congress
here are even more committed
than that.
I'm going to close with this.
The reason the world saw what
Mrs. Till saw was because
another hero in this story.
The black press.
[ Applause ]
Chicago defender, other
newspapers and radio announcers
who told the story for
unflinching the bravery with
which they saw the story, making
sure America saw what they saw.
It was once said, the way to
right wrongs is to turn the
light of truth upon them.
The way to right wrongs is the
shine the light of truth on
them.
That's our charge today.
Did you ever think we'd be
talking about banning books in
America?
Banning history?
I'm serious.
The till family, to all of you
here today, thank you for your
courage, for never giving up,
never giving up.
Before I say what else is on my
mind, I'm not going to leave
this podium.
It's just barbaric.
Seriously, all you moms out
there.
Imagine the courage it took to
say, let them see.
The courage.
It's now my honor to sign this
proclamation in memory of Emmett
till, and I thank you all for
being here.
I am -- I know I'm considered
too much of an optimist, but I
believe if we keep pushing,
we're going to continue to make
progress.
We're going to continue to make
It's already being made.
The idea that when that
14-year-old was buried, this
many people of color holding
powerful office, changed the
direction of the count try.
It would have been beyond our
comprehension.
And we're just getting started
.
>> President Biden is now
signing a proclamation that
officially makes the Emmett till
national monument.
It is a monument that will be in
three separate locations.
One will be in Mississippi near
where he is believed to have
been murdered.
The other will be at the
courthouse in Mississippi, where
an all-white jury acquitted
till's murders.
And then also back in what was
his home state of Illinois,
specifically in Chicago at the
Roberts temple church of god.
That was the church where, as
president Biden just referred
to, his mother demanded that the
funeral she was having for her